à cheval sur le parc naturel de la haute
vallée de chevreuse et l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines magny les
hameaux à une double identité rurale et
urbaine une commune de 9000 491
habitants répartis en sept hameaux et
sur 16 kilomètres carrés un isolement
géographique qui pourrait s'améliorer
grâce à l'augmentation de lignes de bus
ou le développement de pistes cyclables
pour quitter ou accéder à magny les
hameaux de route départementale qui pose
problème la 91 passant par voisins le
bretonneux rapidement combrée en heures
de pointe est source de conflit entre
les deux communes en octobre 2018 côté
château fort la 938 est tout aussi
impactés a été envisagé un temps la
réouverture du chemin vicinal cette
ferme en octobre 2000 par nicolas abou
maire de montigny le bretonneux
après la fermeture des jardins de
cocagne en 2015 la question du passé
agricole de la commune s'est posée la
ferme de bulot y est destiné dans un
premier temps à être vendus ne le sera
finalement pas saint quentin en yvelines
a donné son accord en 2019
un projet de pérennisation agricole de
formation de tourisme et d'insertion est
en cours la ferme de gomberville a été
acheté à sa propriétaire par
l'agglomération celle de la closeraie
accueillera bientôt une chaîne de
transformation de l'aisne de marché de
magny les hameaux et un souhait de
nombreux habitants marché couvert au
marché de plein vent le projet pour le
moment au point mort
un appel lancé auprès de prestataires
franciliens en 2018 s'est soldée par un
échec
une nouvelle tentative a été lancé
auprès des commerçants en juillet 2019
et sa place fait aussi débat